l jean pierre wilhem merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors l'allemagne est
présenté comme un modèle dans la gestion
de la pandémie due coronavirus on l'a
souvent dit néanmoins il y a ce regain
deux cas comment est-ce qu'on peut le
comprendre
d'abord et pour le total le problème
c'est de savoir s'il y aura une deuxième
vague
moi je n'y crois pas beaucoup parce que
il y à une cinétique une dynamique de
virus tout laissait sont favorables
chute la réanimation les morts etc tout
est favorable donc pour l'instant il n'y
aura pas deuxième vague peut-être en eux
en septembre ou octobre
donc en revanche en ce qui concerne donc
l'allemagne
c'est un exemple qui est qui devrait
être réservé aux anthropologues il y a
eu une atteinte d'un zèle dans les
abattoirs 700 personnes atteintes
c'était des gens qui avaient et j'allais
dire qu'ils avaient tout contre eux
c'est à dire pauvreté mauvaise hygiène
une vie concentrationnaire etc
il ne pouvait que développer une
pathologie en revanche en france il ya
eu la fête de larmes de la musique c'est
à dire la joie une explosion émotionnel
avec tous les postillons etc
ils vont s'en sortir cela parce que ils
sont dans une bonne santé et risque de
la voir mais tendant une bonne santé ils
vont l'avoir
et ils vont s'immuniser et puis
favoriser les muni t par l'esc en
allemagne ce cluster cet énorme kloster
c'est pas une bonne situation mais comme
je vous ai dit qu'il y avait une
dynamique dans le virus
il y aura pas même via plusieurs kloster
à travers l'europe
on va bien s'en sortir mais on ce virus
qui c'est un virus à arn et il a
tendance à muter allons donc voir
ressurgir
donc la situation de confinement à la
fois au portugal mais aussi en allemagne
ne vous inquiètent finalement pas tant
que ça non on confine c'est plutôt déjà
lire sur le plan psychologique pas pour
vous dire ressaisissez vous commettez
une erreur
deux tasses ans apporte un bien le leur
confinement il a il apporte un bien mais
le problème c'est que je vous ai dit il
y avait une dynamique du virus si on se
réfère par exemple pas la grippe
espagnole qui est vraiment la grande
grippe de référence il ya eu trois
grands pics qui ont fait 60 millions de
morts et bien il y en a une qui a été
très virulente très mortifère et là il
faut sauter comme ça une pandémie c'est
à dire une épidémie mondiale
on peut s'attendre à tous ces grands
mouvements mais pour l'instant moi mon
avis est jugulée
malgré tout les plis kloster qui
surviennent en europe faut pas s'affoler
le virus est comme un train qui chemine
ena il peut y avoir que j'allais dire à
l'automne et peut ressurgir mais ce même
pas obligatoire mais il faut savoir que
c'est un virus qui mute
on le connaissait déjà sous le forme de
ce sera ce le sera ce le maire aimé y en
a 4 6 qui circulent le corps à norovirus
mais il peut prendre une autre forme
et comment une tendresse à leur goût
virus comment comprendre finalement
qu'en europe vous nous dites que voilà
le virus mute et donc on voit qu'il
disparaît et puis finalement en amérique
latine et bien là bas il explose les
chiffres les chiffres parlent d'eux
mêmes oui parce que ce sont j'allais
dire des grands mouvements géographique
7 on est sur d'autres continents et le
cheminement n'a pas été à la même
vitesse pour chaque continent et chaque
continent bois la même évolution comme
en europe comme il va y avoir un
amérique là t'es comme va y en avoir en
afrique
alors on croit que tout est gagné en
afrique etc mais on ne sait pas il peut
très bien prendre sa virulence d'un
moment à l'autre
merci beaucoup jean pierre willem
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes membre fondateur
de médecins sans frontières
merci